banderas etíopes colorean la espera de
cientos de ciudadanos dispuestos a donar
sangre en la capital de addis abeba las
donaciones por supuesto son para
miembros de las fuerzas armadas que
combaten en la región étnica de tigre
estoy haciendo todo lo que puedo porque
no estoy peleando la tensión entre el
gobierno etíope y el partido frente de
liberación de tigre que controla el
estado no es nueva pero la última semana
ha derivado en lucha militar a un nivel
que amnistía internacional basándose en
fotos y vídeos verificados denuncia que
gran número de civiles habrían sido
masacrados este lunes en la ciudad de
maika dera esta es una tragedia terrible
cuyo verdadero impacto se verá en el
tiempo ya que la comunicación en tigre
sigue caída el gobierno debe restaurar
todas las comunicaciones como
responsabilidad y transparencia de sus
operaciones militares así como
garantizar el acceso sin restricciones a
organizaciones humanitarias y de
derechos humanos el gobierno no solo
acusa de la matanza a las tropas pro
frente de liberación sino que confía
usando sus palabras en una vuelta a la
normalidad para ello ya ha nombrado a un
nuevo líder local
leaf as no opción tal acto de traición
en mi cadera no nos ha dejado más opción
que movilizar nuestras fuerzas para
poner fin a la anarquía que reina en
esta región
de establecimiento esto incluye medidas
como una administración provisional que
me alegra anunciar se está coordinando
con varias ciudades
según la onu más de 14.000 personas han
huido a la vecina sudan 4000 en un día
desde el pasado 4 de noviembre miles ya
dependían de ayudas en tigre lo que ha
llevado a la organización a temer una
crisis humanitaria sin control por eso
exige al gobierno una entrada inmediata
y sin trabas